Yeah, I feel like I heard
we're not supposed to eat a
chick flick in the that you
can't eat anymore. I was somewhere the
other the other day and I was like, oh,
let's go to this restaurant. They like, we
can't. That's a Mario Batali restaurant.
I was like,
I'll and can everyone stop raping people
so I can eat my favorite pasta problem?
Monique telling everybody to
boycott Netflix. Crazy hard,
fucking insane. We getting a half
a million dollars for an hour,
but it's like the Mo for most people
that's still like good at saying fucking
amount. I mean that's an insane
amount of money. It's insane.
As her comparing herself to Chris Rock,
not relatable.
She's not as famous.
Stuff is tricky because if you get
paid based on the value that you bring.
Kathy Griffin,
Kathy Griffin was saying
she would be willing
to do a special bunch,
wants to make sure she gets equal pay
equal pay for women and she was making it
a part of that.
There's so many places.
Here's the thing,
they pay you what they think it's worth
based on how popular you are based on
how popular your stand up,
based on what they think they can get out.
That's why Dave Chappelle gets the most,
that's why Amy Schumer got a lot
not doing that. So for her to
compare herself to those two people,
it's fucking crazy.
Tickets like are their box office for
movies that she was in like, Whoa, Whoa,
whoa. It's like you're not
just getting paid that amount.
You're getting paid when the special
areas that tickets are going to sell
because that's special.
Crazy.
When they start boycott
Netflix
openly,
we're in trouble though
with the Kevin Spacey thing.
They had to do something about that and
they did a lot of money on it. Yeah,
they lost 39 million bucks.
That was where Gore Vidal.
We're not going to hire these people
because it has to be like a bottom line
issue. I'm not going to hire a
rapist because it's too expensive.
Have you ever seen the
Gore Vidal William F.
Buckley documentary where a
details no, no. The opposite.
They hated each other.
British conservative guy who
was very popular during the day.
This is from the 1960s on television
and they were debating back and forth,
Gore Vidal and William F. Buckley,
liberal versus conservative,
but on national television it was like
these really contentious charged debates
and it kind of sunk William f Buckley's
career cause at one time Gore Vidal
called him a Nazi.
You call them a neo Nazi or something,
something along those lines
and then go William F.
Buckley said something called
him a fucking queer and I'll,
I'll punch your face up a sock you in
your nose and you'll stay plastered.
Like lost his cool on television called
him a queer on television and it was
like this whoa moment.
And William F Buckley's
career does that shit.
You got to see who really
is you pressured like,
and I love thinking about what in 30 years
or when you look back and be like, Yo,
I can't believe we used to just
fucking say that. You know like retard.
We used to just say retard.
I still say,
but only the retards but not
just a human.
Who Does the word is not the word is
retarded means like to slow the growth of
something. Retarded ideas,
you know like or like, yeah,
like okay, like denying someone birth
control. That is retarded. Retarded.
It's like socially retarded.
Retarded. It's slowing progress. Yes.
I don't think that's a bad word.
Yeah.
What I think is a bad thing is to
mock someone who has a disability,
but I don't think that you're always
talking about that when you're saying that
word. I think we have a real
problem with language policing.
I think we have a real problem with
denying the use of sounds there.
This would have word supposed to be.
It's like you make a noise so I
understand what you're saying.
I understand like there's, there has to
be context. Like I understand I have to,
it's supposed to be a sound that you make
so I can understand what you're trying
to convey and that's, you say
that's retarded and I go, you mean,
you know that's missing a
chromosome. You know, like it's like,
well that would be me saying that's
down syndrome though. Oh that's true.
You know what I'm saying? I think it's
figuring out what the ideology is.
The word I did not know this happened
recently. Someone said in a writer's room,
um, she's uppity. I did not
know that that was a slave term.
We all learned very quickly
that that was a term. Yes.
The ideology of it was to describe a
slave that was acting out and we learn,
oh wow.
I always thought up but he was someone
who is like a high Falutin like uh,
you know, some rich person. I thought
it was just someone who is um,
for council Trent and would
not participate or who is
resisting but it actually
has origins and same
with like patty wagon.
It's like offensive to Irish people cause
it used to describe drunk Irish people.
Like people don't care.
Trust me in one quarter of course it's
like non Irish people are the ones that
are offensive and funny. That one quarter
Irish, I can't really say I'm Irish,
but if I was one quarter black I'd be,
you would be forever fucking Afro.
That would be a part of the community.
And then what's the other one?
There was another one under your thumb.
If you have someone under your thumb.
It's a rolling stones song,
but it was,
it used to be that was the thickness of
a switch that you could hit your wife
with. It had to be, it couldn't be thicker
than your thumb. Yeah. Like there's the,
like a, is it ediology or edamame
at homology of, um, those words,
which I just didn't know. Um, do you know
the term faggot where that came from?
Uh, cigarettes. No dicks.
Oh, that's right. Right.
And do you know why did it
turn into gay slur? This is,
this was a piss me off on Louis C K show.
They use this urban myth that what it
meant was that a bundle of sticks was a
faggot.
And so I'm a gay man was a faggot cause
they were a bundle of sticks and you
would burn them in a fire.
That's not true at all.
Did he know that we can hire, I don't
know. It's convenient to ignore. Oh,
you to do is research.
It's not hard.
What a bundle of sticks was referred
to was a burden. Some woman,
they would call a burdensome woman,
a Faggot,
because she was like a bundle of sticks.
Very difficult to carry around.
It'd be cocky.
So a man who act like
a woman was a faggot.
Whoa. That's what the term meant. That's
where it came from. That's the whole idea.
That's the absolute origins of that term.
So when people say there was a gay guy
and Louis CK show that was saying then I
was,
it was him and Nick Depalo and Louie were
all playing cards together and someone
said some faggot. And you realize why
that's so offensive is because, you know,
they used to burn people.
There's no fucking history of gay
people being burned like witches. Yeah.
By the way, even the Salem witch
trials, they didn't burn witches.
They drowned them.
Yeah.